Depuis quelque temps je reçois très souvent ce genre de message
Coucou Norman, Je voulais savoir si tu pouvais faire des vidéos où tu réponds à nos questions comme Cyprien et Squeezie..
Alors je me suis dis pourquoi pas ?! Allez c'est parti !
Pourquoi à tu appelé ton chat Sergie ?
Bon, en fait à la base je suis assez fan du chanteur Serge Gainsbourg
Et j'ai appelé mon chat Serge Gainsbourg et j'ai trouvé que le nom était un peu long
Un peu nul à dire tu vois ? Serge Gainsbourg ? Serge Gainsbourg ?!
Voilà c'était excessivement long et ridicule
Du coup au bout d'un moment j'ai dit Serge ! Serge !!
Et comme moi je suis quelqu'un qui aime tout ce qui est mignon
Tout ce qui est diminutif
Ca s'est très vite transformé en : Sergie !
*Mitraillette de bisous"
Je pose une question
Ah.. Bah non justement c'est une affirmation.
Capable de dire ton prénom le plus rapidement possible sans trébucher ahahah
NORMAN ! C'était difficile !
C'est quoi la marque de ton shampoing ?
Alors ça s'appelle.. heu White Spirit !
Tu mesures combien ?
Alors ca c'est une question qu'on me pose souvent
La caméra comme elle est en plongée on dirait que je suis petit, que j'ai un visage de petit
Mais je mesure 1m85
As-tu déjà mis ta main dans une cheminée ?
Bah oui ! Plein de fois !
Par contre elle était éteinte ! ( clin oeil )
T'as eu quelle mention au bac ?
Ah déjà, c'est marrant parce que tu dis ça comme si évidemment j'avais eu une mention
Parce que moi je me souviens qu'au bac
Comme mention j'ai eu pas de mention
Et estimez vous heureux de l'avoir, fils de chien !
Pense tu que tout est relatif ?
Ca dépend !
Pourquoi tu ne te présente pas aux élections présidentielles ?
Parce que si j'étais président de la république tu vois
Je pense que la France ça ressemblerai à ça !
Ton boisson préféré ?
Bah je pense que mon boisson préféré c'est le bière
Quel est ta série/musique/chaine TV/gâteau/portable/goûter préféré, quel est ton gamertag sur  LOL / dota
Nan mais attends, j'cois que faut que j'fasse une vidéo spéciale pour répondre que à ta question
Ton genre de fille
Heu... franchement, moi j'aime bien les meufs un peu dans ce style là [photo pas jolie jolie]
Nan franchement moi j'aime bien tous les types de filles, tant qu'elles sont gentilles, tu vois tant qu'elles sont sincères, naturelles, tant qu'il y a de la gentillesse qui passe dans le regard, comme ça
Bah moi ça me convient.
Si tu n'aurais pas été youtubeur, à ton avis qu'aurais tu été?
Avant de faire des vidéos, j'ai fait pas mal de petits jobs alimentaires et puis j'ai finis par être monteur en fait
monteur vidéo pendant 2 ans
Donc j'pense que j'aurais continué à être monteur
Ça te fait quoi d'avoir une calvitie à a peine 26 ans ? Euh bon déjà, j'ai de la chance de ne pas avoir de calvitie et à quel moment tu t'es dit : "Je vais pécho des meufs en m'appelant sur Twitter, Ben Laden ?
Sinon, ça c'est vraiment euh, c cédille
À quoi tu ressemblais quand tu étais petit (claquement de doigt + photo de lui petit)
Vas-tu faire un one man show ? Alors beaucoup m'ont posé cette question, et la réponse est oui !
Comme certains le savent, en parallèle à mes vidéos, je fais aussi des one man show depuis plus d'un an maintenant et là ça y est j'annonce donc euh la tournée officielle qui commence en septembre prochain !
Ce qui est cool, c'est que je vais pas que dans les grandes villes, je vais aussi dans les petites villes. Et puis enfin je serais à Paris à la Cigale à partir de Février 2015 !
Pour voir si je viens jouer dans votre ville et pour réserver des places,  j'ai mis un petit lien dans la description en dessous de la vidéo !
Bon, je suis hyper photoshopé, on dirait que j'ai huit ans, mais ça c'est parce qu'à la base, je suis très moche ! (Bonjour !)
J'ai aussi eu certaines questions un peu spéciales donc je vais quand même vous en parlez : "Pourquoi t'es arabe ?" (Gros blanc et Norman s'en va du champ)
Bah je ne suis pas arabe, hein ni même musulman même si j'ai dans mon frigo des produits halal, hein voilà, que je consomme. Euh, merci John Rachid !
Est-ce que tu as déjà pleurer en faisant caca, genre des fois ça fais mal... T"as l'impression que c'est une fusée qui sort !
Là, là, t'as vraiment un souci mental !
Comptes tu venir à BX pour ton one man show ?
Alors si BX ça veut dire Bordeaux, oui ou alors si BX ça veut dire Bruxelles , euh oui, par contre si tu parle de la ville de BX (Ville de BX), je crois pas !
Que fais tu quand tu est tout seul chez toi  avec une meuf ? Euh, c'est quoi cette question ? Bah comme tout le monde : On mange des kebabs !
Comment il s'appelle Sergi ? Pas mal !
What ? Le mec tweet ça depuis New York, normal !
C'est quoi ton jeu vidéo préféré ? Alors c'est vrai qu'en ce moment je joue pas mal à Hearthstone ! Hein, j'ai un prêtre level 26, hein, c'est à dire que j'ai un certain niveau ! Euh...
*Partie de Hearthstone" Défaite ! Non mais là j'avais pas une bonne pioche !
Quelle activité quotidienne préfère-tu ? Euh, bah faire des vidéos, clairement et faire du one man show aussi ! Mais je te cache pas qu'avec les filles, j'aime bien manger des kebabs !
Et euh et après à un moment donné... Attends t'as un peu de sauce blanche là ! Non mais c'est super bon ! D'accord !
Eh ouais et je te disais...
Voilà c'est terminé, j'espère que ça vous a plu ! Euh dites moi ce que vous en pensez dans les commentaires ! Peut-être qu'on refera plus tard un autre questions/réponses, qui sait, hein, que cela ne tienne !
Allez Ciao !